Me perguntaram recentemente, tenho 52
anos de idade e quais seriam os
suplementos que eu deveria tomar todos
os dias? Isso é bem variável. Vamos,
vamos tentar ajudar. Sabe aquela
história de que depois dos 50 a gente
começa a sentir o corpo pedir um
pouquinho mais de atenção? Pois é, hoje
vamos ter uma conversa franca sobre
isso. Imagine que você acorda de manhã e
ao invés daquela energia de quando você
tinha 30, você sente como se o motor
precisasse de um tempinho a mais para
esquentar. Normal, pessoal. Mas olha só
que interessante, isso. Nosso corpo é
uma máquina fantástica que pode ser
turbinada com os nutrientes certos. Eu
vou contar uma coisa para vocês. Aos 52,
seu corpo, seu organismo está passando
por mudanças bioquímicas profundas. É
como se fosse um carro clássico, sabe?
Ainda roda que é uma beleza, mas precisa
de uma manutenção mais caprichada. E é
aqui que entram os suplementos, não como
muletas, mas como aliados estratégicos
nessa jornada do envelhecimento
saudável. Começando pelo básico, mais
poderoso, a vitamina D de dado três.
Olha que coisa curiosa, depois dos 50,
nossa pele perde cerca de 70% da
capacidade de produzir vitamina D
através do sol. 70% é muita coisa, não
é? Por isso que mesmo morando num país
tropical como o nosso, a deficiência de
vitamina D é uma epidemia silenciosa. E
não estamos falando só de ossos fracos
dão. A vitamina D modula mais de 3.000
genes do nosso corpo. Sistema imune,
humor, força muscular, até sensibilidade
à insulina. Tudo depende dela. A dose
que a medicina funcional preconiza seria
entre 2.000 a 10.000 por dia unidades
internacionais, sempre checando os
níveis sanguíneos para manter entre 40 e
70. Mas pera aí, não adianta vitamina D
sozinha, ela precisa de uma parceira
fundamental que é a K2, especialmente a
MK7. Sabe por quê? A vitamina D aumenta
a absorção de cálcio, mas quem direciona
esse cálcio pros ossos, ao invés de
deixar ele se depositar nas artérias, é
a K2. É tipo um GPS de cálcio no corpo.
Sem ela, você pode estar calcificando
suas artérias enquanto os seus ossos
continuam fracos. A dose fica entre 100
a 200 microg por dia. E já que estamos
falando desse trio fantástico, não
podemos esquecer do magnésio. O magnésio
participa de mais de 300 reações
enzimáticas do nosso organismo. É o
maestro de orquestra celular. Então, o
problema é que nossos solos brasileiros
estão cada vez mais pobres em magnésio e
o stress do dia a dia consome nossas
reservas numa velocidade impressionante.
Sabe aquela câbra chata, aquela insônia
teimosa, aquele intestino preguiçoso?
Tudo pode ter a ver com deficiência em
magnésio. O ideal é usar formas queladas
com bisglicinato ou magnésio de malato
numa dose de 400 a 600 mg por dia. Agora
vamos falar de energia celular. Lembra
quando eu disse que o corpo é como um
carro clássico? Então a cozima Q10 é
como aditivo prêmio da gasolina. Depois
dos 50 nossa produção de com enzima que
é 10 despenca em até 70%. Isso significa
menos energia nas mitocôndrias, que são
aquelas usinas de energia das nossas
células. E não é só fadiganão. O
coração, que é o órgão que mais precisa
de energia sofre muito com essa
deficiência. uma dose de 100 a 200 mg de
biquinol, que é a forma mais ativa da
coisa, que é 10, pode fazer uma
diferença tremenda. E o ômega-3 a esse é
o anti-inflamatório da natureza. Vivemos
numa sociedade pró-inflamatória com
comida processada, estresse, poluição.
Tudo isso gera inflamação crônica, que é
o combustível do envelhecimento.
Ômega-3, especialmente o EPA e o DHA,
são como bombeiros apagando esses
incêndios silenciosos no corpo. Mas
atenção, tem que ser de boa qualidade,
certificado IFO, IFOS, senão você está
tomando óleo de peixe oxidado, que faz
mais mal que bem. E a dose terapêutica
fica entre 2 a 4 g por dia. E a vitamina
B12, minha gente, essa é crucial. Depois
de 50, cerca de 30% das pessoas têm
dificuldade de absorver B12 dos
alimentos. E não é frescura, não. B12
baixa causa desde fadiga e depressão até
problemas neurológicos sérios. Aquela
sensação de formigamento nas
extremidades, memória falhando, pode ser
B12 baixa. O ideal é usar a formaalamina
sublingual ou injetável, porque a
absorção intestinal já não é a mais a
mesma. Agora vou compartilhar algo mais
avançado com vocês. Os precursores de
nadis. demais, é tipo a moeda energética
das células e seus níveis caem
drasticamente com a idade. Então o Dr.
David Sinclair de Harvard tomava ou toma
1 g de NMNA nicotinamida,
mononucleotídio todos os dias isso ajuda
a ativar as cituínas que são as
proteínas da longevidade. Junto com o
NMN ele toma 1 g de resveratrol, aquele
antioxidante do vinho tinto, mas de uma
dose impossível de conseguir beber no
vinho. Isso pode ser um pouco
questionável. Então você pode obter
também esse mesmo nutriente através da
vitamina B3, aniacina. Falando em
antioxidantes, a quecetina merece
destaque especial. Ela é um flavonoide
que não só combate os radicais livres,
mas também tem propriedades senolíticas,
ou seja, ela ajuda a eliminar células
velhas e disfuncionais do nosso corpo. É
como fazer uma faxina celular, então uma
dose de 500 mg por dia pode fazer
maravilhas pela sua saúde. E o colágeno?
Bom, aos 52 anos já perdemos cerca de
30% do nosso colágeno. Pele flasta,
articulações rangendo, cabelo a fracos,
tudo tem a ver com colágeno. Mas não é
qualquer colágeno, não. Tem que ser
hidrolizado com peptídeos bioativos uma
dose de pelo menos 10 g por dia. E
sempre combinem com vitamina C, que é um
cofator da síntese colágeno. Agora, um
suplemento que está bombando nas
pesquisas mais recentes, que é a
glutaationa, é o nosso antioxidante
mestre do corpo e é produzido pelo
fígado, mas que diminui drasticamente
qualidade. Então a gluta não só combate
o estresse oxidativo, como também é
fundamental paraa desintoxicação
hepática. Então o problema é que glutati
oral tem baixa absorção, então a solução
usar a forma lipossomal ou a forma
sublingual ou ainda os precursores, como
é o caso do NAC, aciteína junto com a
glicina. Também podemos falar aqui dos
tocotrienois que são da vitamina E, são
da família da vitamina E são
neuroprotetores potentes. Protege o
cérebro do declíni cognitivo e trabalham
em sinergia com a vitamina C e o
selênio, formando uma rede antioxidante
poderosa. Então, uma dose de
tocotrienóis na cerca de 400 unidades
por dia pode fazer diferença. O zinho
que é lado uma dose de 15 a 30 mg por
dia é fundamental pro sistema imune.
especialmente agora que estamos mais
velhos e nosso timo já não produz tantas
células T como antes, mas cuidados
zincos pode interferir na absorção de
cobre, então o equilíbrio é fundamental.
E o selena, esse mineral é traço, mas
ele é cofator da cruta peroxidase, que é
uma das enzimas antioxidantes mais
importantes do corpo. Então o Brasil,
nós sabemos, é rico em castanho do
Brasil ou castanho do Pará. É uma das
melhores fontes selênio, mas mesmo assim
muita gente tem deficiência. Então, uma
dose de três aí castanhas por dia, que
vai equivaler a 100 a 200 microg por
dia, é uma boa ideia. Agora, para fechar
com chave de ouro, vamos falar de time
em sinergia. Não adianta tomar tudo de
uma vez. Vitamina D3, K2 e magnésio
podem vir juntos, de preferência com uma
refeição que temha gordura boa. Ômega-3
e co enzima 10 também vão bem juntos e
com gordura. B12 é melhor sublingual em
jejum. Colagem pode ser tomada a
qualquer hora, mas muita gente prefere à
noite porque ajuda no sono reparador. E
olha, não estou dizendo para sair
tomando tudo isso junto sem orientação.
Cada corpo é único, cada pessoa tem as
suas necessidades específicas. O ideal é
fazer exames, ver onde estão as suas
deficiências e suplementar de forma
personalizada. Medicina funcional é
isso, tratar a pessoa e não a idade.
Lembrem-se, a suplementação é apenas uma
peça do quebra-cabeça. Alimentação de
qualidade é muito importante. Comer
comida de verdade, exercício físico
regular, especialmente musculação para
combater a sarcopenia, sono de
qualidade, gestão do estresse, conexões
sociais. Tudo isso é fundamental. Os
suplementos são os aliados que
potencializam esses pilares. Aos 52
anos, a gente não está velho, está
experiente e com os nutrientes certos
podemos ter energia, vitalidade e saúde
para curtir tudo que a vida ainda tem
para oferecer. Porque envelhecer
inevitável, mas envelhecer mal é
opcional. Então, a escolha é nossa e
começa com decisões que tomamos hoje
sobre como cuidar desse corpo que nos
trouxe até aqui e ainda tem muito
caminho pela frente.